hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
welcome to the hackintosh pro project
part three alright so for those of you
who are new to this project boom there
are parts one and two annotated or there
are the first two links in the
description below the like button on
this video but basically in those two
videos we go over basically the gist of
the hackintosh Pro project and then we
assemble all of the parts of the
hackintosh Pro project this is the part
where we're going to actually build it
together and make any computer now you
might see behind me that's actually
already put together but you're about to
watch the video of me putting all the
parts together to hopefully give you a
better idea of why I chose the parts but
I just want to say if you do want to
behind-the-scenes look at how this is
going already you can follow me on
Twitter which is where I've been posting
some behind the scenes pictures for on
Google+ so again those two links are
also below the like button and that's
where we get these things basically the
point of this part of the build is to
show you guys why I chose certain parts
for example I chose the H ATI as cooler
a lot of people were yelling at me you
should have chosen H 100 I but you know
with this combination of a motherboard
and a case it would have been very
difficult to fit the H 100 I in so I
chose the H JD I basically the whole
point is to show you that this is being
built now and then we're going to go
ahead and get to the fun stuff so anyway
enjoy and this is me building the
hackintosh pro so interestingly enough
the only tool we're going to need to fit
all these parts together into a fully
functioning computer dual booting
operating systems and becoming a beast
of a rig for 2013 is a screwdriver well
two screwdrivers actually one is larger
for the more heavy-duty stuff so we'll
start with the empty fractal r4 case and
a fractal thousand watt power supply now
you can see it is semi modular there's
some cables in it already and I think I
said it was fully modular in the other
video but basically what I'm immediately
beginning here by putting it in this
case is cable management good air flow
is important to any build and of course
my OCD kicks in here and wants this
thing to be as neat as possible so we're
going to take full advantage of the room
behind the motherboard tray to tuck
those cables back and really give the
parts room to breathe fractals power
supply also comes with a ton of power
cables for all our peripherals which is
nice and even cable ties to help us out
anyway next up is the motherboard the
asus saber
2x 79 military-grade socket 2011
motherboard this thing is quite a beast
and the board also comes with a bunch of
accessories so once we get the board out
of the box you'll see it comes with
accessories like the back IO shield
which is always important a small fan
that is optional to install and then you
also get of course all of your SATA
cables and it comes with six the
white-tipped ones would you get four of
our the full-speed SATA 6 gigabits per
second SATA cable so that's what I'll be
using for the SSDs when we do those
later and of course like any other
motherboard you get some miscellaneous
screws and adapters and even an sli
bridge and you also get a sticker which
is neat I don't know if we going to put
that on your case or not but you do get
a sticker and most importantly you also
get some actual useful paperwork here
every motherboard is different so I use
the diagrams and instructions in this
paperwork to figure out which Ram slops
to use which cables go where etc so
first things first you install the i/o
shield in the back of the case it just
snaps on the back of the fractal r4 just
like it should it's pretty durable so
don't worry about bending it you can
pretty much snap right in place and we
use that to guide the motherboard into
the case when we do that later then I
actually pause for a bit just to take a
look around this motherboard I took it
out of the wrapping and it is seriously
a work of art if you check this thing
out it is just a beautiful piece of
engineering in such a small space it's
also quite heavy for the way it looks
and for the size but it is just covered
in chips and dims and heat sinks in
silicon everywhere I know it's not the
prettiest color scheme in the world not
everyone likes the green but then again
you know how often do you peek into your
computer and stare at the motherboard
not very often but you know for those of
you want to match colors you might want
to look elsewhere but yes so we can take
the stickers off this rim and we're
basically left with a naked motherboard
ready for the CPU so that's what we'll
break out next this is it this is the
Intel Core i7 3930k 6 core cpu running
at 3.2 gigahertz stock with an unlocked
multiplier for easy overclocking this
thing is going to be great like I
mentioned in the last video this build
is going to be a workhorse of a video
editing and rendering machine so that's
very CPU heavy tasks so it's why I chose
this guy as the brains of the build now
it is a 2011 socket so this is catch
kind of a big CPU it's kind of like
having your own personal Xeon processor
and when you take it out the box you can
see all the golden pins on the back but
be careful when handling this it is
easily the most expensive part per
square inch of this whole machine but
again just it's really fun to admire
these parts so now comes one of the more
fun parts installing the CPU onto the
motherboard if you've seen the
instructional videos you already know
how to do this you don't have to touch
the top or bottom of the CPU in fact you
don't want to you just want to lay it to
rest right on top of the pins without
inserting any pressure then close it up
and that's it CPU installed you might
feel like you're putting a ton of
pressure on the clamps - you might feel
like you're going to snap them in half
or something but that's normal once you
close them these are tough clamps tough
board tough stuff the CPU is done now
there are some golden screws that came
with this case these are the motherboard
standoffs that you need to install these
into the ATX holes of the case the
motherboard will then rest on top of
these in order to separate it from the
metal of the actual case and then we get
more screws to screw the board into
place on top of these standoffs so that
it's held snug next we'll break out the
RAM this is 32 gigs of Corsair Vengeance
Ram running at 1600 megahertz it's
enough ram to give Adobe Premiere and
After Effects plenty of room to breathe
which is the basic point of this but
this board also actually has eight Ram
slots and this is only four sticks of
RAM each eight gigabyte sticks so if I
ever need to upgrade to 64 gigabytes of
ram in the future I have four slots open
and I can add four more a gigabyte ram
dims and be at 64 gigs of ram so this
motherboards paperwork of course shows
us the best place to install quad
channel memory with four dims which is
what we're doing here and the RAM
installation is probably the simplest
part you might even skip this part you
just pull back the plastic tabs on the
dims that you want to use and seat the
memory sticks into place very simple as
long as you install them in the right
place I'm sure a lot of you guys have
already either done this before or have
seen it done before next up is the CPU
cooler the Corsair H ATI
now like I mentioned I picked the H ATI
over the H 100 because we're going for a
completely silent build and the
combination of the motherboards heat
sinks and this case don't really leave
any room for a dual fan radiator in the
top so we're going with a single
radiator closed-loop water cooling
solution for our soon to be overclocked
pee-yew inside the box of course you get
the pump and the reservoir which is the
main unit but you also get a bunch of
mounting gear for both Intel and AMD
processors you just have to pick the
right one for your build as well as two
corsair fans which turned out to be
quite loud so I later replace them with
Noctua fans and I'll show those in a
later video here's a closer look at the
H ATI radiator this is what's going to
be going in the back of the case and
here's the pump which sits right on the
CPU and it actually lights up different
colors when it's on now for the
installation there was already a fractal
hundred 40 millimeter fan in the back of
the case so I removed this and instead
added it to the dual radiator panel on
the front which means we now have two
large fans in the front of the case and
then we'll use the fan for the courser h
adi in the back so that really directs
air flow straight from the front to the
back of the case the radiator was then
attached to the back fan which again I
replaced with a much nicer nock to a fan
that I'll show later so when you flip
the case around you'll see a pretty
large sized cutout behind the
motherboard tray this is where you grab
the LGA 2011 bracket and mount it behind
the motherboard and then that let me
attach the CPU cooler to the CPU in the
front inside the case
so for cooling H Adi mission
accomplished
next thing and with a very last large
part anyway is a graphics card our
gigabyte geforce gtx 670 overclocked
edition with two gigabytes of video RAM
and 1344 cuda cores which Adobe programs
love so much this is another one of
those parts like the motherboard that is
really complex and detailed and almost
beautiful in a way that you can actually
see from the outside which I thought was
cool but basically you can see the
triple fan silent cooling solution here
that keeps it so quiet installation of a
PCI card is of course very simple you
just drop the place holders out of the
case and snap the video card into the
PCI slot that you want to use in my case
it's the very first one at the top of
the motherboard then you can put the
screws back in just to hold up the video
cards wait since it actually would kind
of strain the motherboard without any of
the support from the screws so we are
almost done here all the biggest parts
are now in the case the last thing we
have left to tackle are air solid-state
drives and I've always loved unboxing
these SSDs always just so neat and
simple no real and struck
is necessary they come with stickers
they're just awesome and ocz really
knows what they're doing with these SSDs
I use them in the fastest Mac Mini in
the world project
these are vertex fours now so they're
even better have better controllers for
larger data transfers which is better
for video editing and if I had a nickel
for every time someone told me these are
going to fail I'd probably be a
millionaire by now but trust me if these
ever fail me or even stop working or
even hiccup I will be the first to let
you know but I've never had any problems
in the fastness Mac Mini in the world so
if you want to watch that series that
link will be right down below the like
button on this video but as you can see
the fractal are four handles these SSDs
quite nicely and they all go in the
bottom right next to a fan so they'll
have cool air blowing over them just a
really neat design especially if you
want to add more hard drives with media
storage in the future so now that every
part is inside the case this is what it
looks like with no power or data cables
everything is totally naked and bam that
is what it looks like when I connect all
the cables power to the motherboard
graphics cards SSDs fans and everything
etc everything is now connected and I
think with my pretty amateur cable
management it turned out pretty clean
you can see an even better view here of
the top of the case where there is just
enough room for everything I love this
case it has the noise dampening material
inside of it and the power supply and
the fans I have in here are also now
super quiet the graphics card and its
extra fan allow them to spin at a lower
rpm so they're also very quiet and the
SSD only solution is completely silent
of course with no moving parts I can
tell you from experience you can't tell
by listening whether this machine is on
or not it's that good and overall
there's still room for expansion too so
there's extra PCI slots open here at the
bottom half of the motherboard so you
can add another graphics card later and
there's four extra Ram slots open up on
the top of the motherboard so this is a
huge reason to choose a hackintosh over
a mac pro for this type of flexibility
but that's a whole other video so feel
free to leave a comment if you want to
see a dedicated video on the Mac Pro
versus hackintosh but either way I think
my favorite part of this build is
definitely the case I'm just a huge fan
of the black and white color scheme sort
of an inverted stormtrooper look that
matches the rest of my setup especially
the front of it we've got a matte black
look to it and you can
open up the magnetically held front to
reveal a fan controller which is
actually pretty convenient with three
different voltages so I can turn it up
while we run during a video and the
front do 140 millimeter white fans that
come with the case it's just really nice
overall a real keeper here and even
those side panel doors are particularly
heavy with the sound dampening material
on the inside but this is it the build
is officially complete and now it's time
to power it up and in the next video
we're going to make it a hackintosh Pro
thanks for watching
be sure to subscribe to see the next one
and stay tuned
[Music]
you